wir befinden uns jetzt auf den spuren
der radiogeschichte im haus des
rundfunks 1931 hier in berlin erbaut
damals war es das einzige gebäude
europas das ausschließlich dem rundfunk
dient hat dieser lichthof sollte
symbolhaft für die wahren und hellen
informationen stehen die das haus
ausstrahlen sollte
so hat sich der architekt hans poelzig
das damals jedenfalls vorgestellt ein
wunsch den nicht erfüllt wird
goebbels ersetzt das gesamte personal
durch nsdap-mitglieder und hohe ns
funktionäre das gebäude hier nennen die
nationalsozialisten ab 1938 die zentrale
des großdeutschen rundfunks zwei jahre
später wird überall nur noch ein reiches
programm gesendet und das radio wird zum
wichtigsten propaganda instrument mit
gerade einmal 17 jahren fängt richard
baier als der bis dahin jüngste
nachrichtensprecher bank groß deutschen
rundfunk an
optimismus verbreiten das ist seine
wichtigste aufgabe bevölkerung wird über
die wahre kriegssituationen nicht
informiert als die kämpfe berlin
erreichen
friedrich hat bayer im frühjahr 45 in
einen beton geschützten sendewoche und
verließ dann von dort aus die propaganda
berichte der wehrmacht ist ganz zum
schluss ich will für hauptquartier 20
man nur der wir machen
trotz der gegenwehr de
den feindlichen panzer kräften aus dem
raum müncheberg weisen aus dem westen
und süden bis
preuß vorzustoßen
gegenangriff
gesetze amerikanische kampfverbände
waffen bomben auf sie deutsches gebiet
in der nacht waren orte in schleswig
holstein und die reichshauptstadt das
angriffsziel britischer terror bombe
das verbindet tolle karriere gemacht
beim gros bayerischen rundfunk an
was du angefangen hast über der biete
und länder gesprochen dann befristete
steht sind dann über vorsteht
und jetzt jetzt sprichst du schon über
am bahnhof und warte mal ab
du sprichst darüber etagen
nur der wehrmacht gibt bekannt dass
heroische regelt dass es hier
statt
möglichkeit auch in charlottenburg ist
der kampf in brand zahlreiche panzer der
sowjets wurden in diesen kämpfen
vernichtet
berlin die stadt der warenhäuser
da warenhäuser und da warenhäuser ich
sehe wie die da draußen zwischen
durchsagen klamotten burg steglitz steht
nix lichterfelde west trichter felder
west liegt gleich neben lichterloh aus
wir sitzen hier in einem
schallisolierten bunker und verbreiten
die märchen des okw selbst der
galgenhumor milch für die
stoppt den stadtkern
damit beendet der großdeutsche rundfunk
seine sende folgen
wir grüßen alle deutschen und gedenken
noch einmal des heroischen deutschen
soldatentums zu lande zu wasser und in
der luft
der führer ist tot es lebe das reich
mit diesen worten endet schließlich das
programm des großdeutschen rundfunks und
etwa neun stunden danach besetzt die
rother media dieses gebäude am 13 mai 45
nur fünf tage nachdem deutschland
kapituliert hatte geht von hier aus der
berliner rundfunk auf sendung
mit einem einstündigen programm unter
anderem darin die nationalhymnen der
vier siegermächte und auch eine
botschaft stahlen die letzte sowjetische
wachmannschaft verlässt erst 1956 das
haus danach zieht der sender freies
berlin herein und fusioniert 2003
schließlich mit dem ostdeutschen
rundfunk brandenburg und heraus kam der
rundfunk berlin brandenburg
der rbb hat also nun die wichtige
aufgabe die hellen und waren
informationen von mir zu verbreiten so
wie es sich der architekt damals
gewünscht hat das haus des rundfunks ein
ort mit viel geschichte und jeder menge
symbolkraft